[Music]
oh hell yeah all right we're gonna have
to murder some a-holes or what i hope so
then we get more tokens
oh come on is that all you gathered wade
grappling hook alright get ready get
ready get ready your lives are about to
change
uh
oh no i'm full [ __ ] there was wood i
couldn't grab because i'm full what
i got grabbed a lot of resources i see
being left behind well go get it i'm
being attacked
wait grappling hook
did but i researched it maybe research
it again but better this time but it
didn't give any information
about to be attacked again get your
pistols ready oh i bet we have to build
it at the armory or something yeah
there's a tool grappling quickly
iron bars two springs one copper thingy
it's at the
what am i muted no i hear you i hear you
hear you wade just interrupted me with
the wrong answer while i was giving you
the end yes
i said grab the grappling hook you can
craft it right here and i was reading
the ingredients and you were like we
need to build the armory
that's the only thing i said here's the
grappling hook this is what he needs but
i thought before you did
[Music]
i heard you after i was done talking
he turned me into formula one firewood
no
sometimes it's really nice but sometimes
i miss the touch of another human
okay all right guys
back at it again
did we use the springs
did we use the springs uh because we
need for the for the grappling hook we
need some stuff
yeah we do we sure do don't we always do
oh
good
oh i see you down there i don't know
what the hell the big eyeball thing that
we shoot is for annoyance all these
greases are so stupid
yeah don't touch my heart
wait we need food and water not unusable
green [ __ ] all i'm grabbing is wood
metal food and water yeah you'd be
surprised everything except for the one
thing we told you not to grab explicitly
yeah yeah i know you're welcome it's not
very limited
don't act like you're not still grabbing
it we know you're still grabbing it i
grabbed this one
don't touch that because i wanted to be
defiant that's the only one i've grabbed
wait it's going to have a full inventory
of that dumb [ __ ] i just wrote my
inventory that doesn't prove anything
they're liars
your audience above all of our audiences
cannot be trusted yeah absolutely you're
right but like my video evidence is
pretty video and everything wade's
inventory is full of nothing but green
group changed my mind he literally
dumped everything else that was useful
and filled it with green
he's he's bitterly throwing wood away
because he's mad
don't tempt me to do it you don't need
to tempt you do it anyway you're already
doing that anyway oh put a ruffle on
your head and call it a hat what what
what happening hey you uh i mean our
heroes noticed alien lights luring them
deeper into the void what could it be a
mysterious witch island perhaps
what's happening what is happening
oh wait look to the left boys
oh it's time hey mark you got those
rings yeah i got the rings here i'll set
him up for us mark ring us out there i'm
gonna ring us out there ring me daddy
wait i don't have any rings i don't need
rings i can use my springs you can use
mark springs
oh we can attach to this weird i don't
know this potato here oh
i'm on my way
what is this
i knew there was something here
you can grab one of the potatoes i
really want a potato right now do you
guys just ever really want a baked
potato i don't want one of those
potatoes i gotta be honest
i'm risking it i missed it
i missed it oh god
okay got it flying away into the abyss
as close to that potato one as possible
god i hope we have enough rings
which island solve the puzzle it says
solve the puzzle what does it mean
puzzles all of the poos
can we attach to any of this
i don't want to waste any more but
i don't see anything completely
up there
okay oh yeah okay okay
i'm here on the
can i be on oh i'm gonna touch this leaf
because it looks so friendly and
inviting there's a potato in here yeah
oh
don't shoot at it randomly what's wrong
with you i'm just curious your curiosity
makes you shoot things
yeah that's a good idea oh i see there's
much more
damn it there's more [ __ ] deeper in here
is there a potato on this island there's
a potato in there but i think we're too
far from it here let me
okay i have six of these left so i gotta
be real careful here all right
and
that's the wrong button
got it
no
wait no i got it hey i made it
okay yeah just yeah you you kind of got
over there
i'm real [ __ ] right now is anyone else
real [ __ ] right now no no
no oh there's a potato here
potato
organic this is what i got from in here
okay is there a potato that we can grab
that's through here yes it can oh oh i
went through the building whoa what is a
jar
what's the puzzle
i don't know but there's a big old thing
of
something there's a big sphere oh i hate
this sphere
oh i hate this sphere
oh i hate this there's some kind of
goopers in here yeah there's a sphere
are you guys over here
no i i was i took me i got screwed up
navigate
yeah
where are you mark did you keep going
i'm all the way in oh i see a sphere i
see a sphere yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh
i can rotate the lasers yeah i can well
i think we got to rotate it to the
sphere oh
krusty i see or maybe the screamy dudes
or
oh yeah do it get in his mouth
get in the mouth yeah yeah yeah get see
the lights on the pillar lit up when you
got it in the mouth is that doing it
yeah it's doing it okay
yeah screaming the other one yeah yeah
yeah yeah there we go
okay okay bob go over to it or something
i don't know
i'm trying
one's blue and one's yellow is that good
this thing's crying
is that good
is there a third one we haven't hit
is it nice
oh i see i see i think i gotta bounce
this one off something else oh oh oh
shoot it shoot it through here shoot it
through through in here maybe yeah wait
maybe no i'm reflecting can you uh bob
can you maybe that was right because oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah i see what you're
working on how do you how did you rotate
did you like hit e on or something yeah
yeah yeah just i went really close to
hitting
i can't seem to grab it
that one doesn't rotate
maybe the one inside rotates
maybe yeah it looks like it do but this
one this one is firing into a wall that
doesn't seem right yeah go go go
can you hit the one inside no i'm not
wait wait mark you see that one
which one can you hit that one oh am i
no this doesn't reach up there okay so
oh okay i think wade you're supposed to
go that one i can aim this one at it if
you can hit the one in the house i can
name it
i can't it doesn't hit though
it doesn't that doesn't mean there you
go yeah yeah no that way that's correct
is that is that doing anything go up go
up a bit
you you had it for like the briefest
second
hey for a second how do we get these
down shoot him
[Music]
the answer was shooting bob you're
instinct
i was right the whole time the answer
was shooting
okay so that's what we want
man we're americans we should have known
that man what exactly were you shooting
we destroyed parts of the house
oh okay oh oh so the lasers couldn't
pass through
the chest the chest what's it okay
i don't know i picked it up though oh
hell yeah
i got it oh yeah
chester valuable rewards you need to
bring them to the training
sacrifice the table of sacrifice the
sacrifice
finally we get the people this is a
really terrible thing to have to carry
in my arms but i'll do it let's do it
well this game got more interesting all
of a sudden yeah that's pretty neat i
was wondering when it was going to get
more story because the story like hasn't
progressed since we
started
yeah wait careful this is a bad area
it's fighting me
i will i will stay
i choose to be here you guys uh you guys
good you don't sound good oh it's some
serious issues with the grappling yeah
it's uh wait where do we go wait wait
where did you guys go where do we go
uh
guys oh i'm in fog i'm in fog i don't
see [ __ ] go through the fog there's
potatoes there are potatoes
i don't see potatoes there's no way to
see something i see a grappling spot
maybe
okay
okay yeah you're coming the right way
bob you're coming the right way i see
you oh yeah i'm coming don't worry
that's great
it gets really hard to see every time i
do anything so
i don't really plan this out okay
i see our train we're so close
very much considering that i'm the one
who has the only thing of value we just
got i could start the train right now
no that's a train
i'm under
well at least i'm attached to the train
okay
can i set this down yes i can place
guys i'm placing the chest
why would you drink the chest blood
uh that was a private matter
give me your fat god they never give fat
there's no fat on those guys i mean
they're tiny little guys what do you
expect fat
whole heard of them
i think we shot the same one like three
times
we [ __ ] murdered that guy
he is out of here
all right shall we yeah
[Music]
so how do we know when's the time to go
for those and when is it the fireflies
yeah because there's like a big island
off to the right but i don't know if we
can go to that one fireflies
you know i was doing the left side but
that's fine just swim right over my head
all right always something to complain
about over the right side that's fine
just keep taking my spots that's fine
yeah well maybe you should be in the
front if you really care about that okay
there's
uh not the stuff anyone cares about it's
like the goop you all hate that fat fat
i'm going back
it's leather it's leather it's like
hey there's some more of those [ __ ]
over here
hey fat mark i made you fat mark get the
back
thank you
i made that for you buddy thank you pal
also pick up dirty water if you guys see
it just fyi um i'm getting all the ice
clean and dirty
all right i'm making a grappling hook
because i don't know what to do now
it was right in front of me and i
couldn't hit it yeah one of them yeah
well it took two tries and it was right
in front of me my aim
should give me you killed
killed that time i definitely killed
that fat
fat
goddammit did you miss it did you not
get it i did it was too far i thought i
could reach this too far away
you need like nothing i guess
too far down like you couldn't get to it
even if you were right by it
do we need fat or are you just focusing
on that it's good it's it's like if you
use it as fuel it's just as good as wood
okay well then yeah okay whoa
so we can use fat for fuel
wait a minute oh no you're stuck in here
yeah all right buddy
grandpa you all right what happened to
you
hallelujah
wait a minute
hold the phone
holy [ __ ]
guys and gals i'm about to make you
something beautiful oh get yourself a
grappling hook my boys get yourself a
grapple hook
wait a minute it hold on it works for a
moment it did
work for a moment
wait hold on if you had to grab you
trying to grapple that oh there you go
you're trying to grab do you need the
dirty wife do you dirty ice for anything
crazy research research research okay i
have some search i put a whole bunch in
a chest too
uh i'm gonna look for the dirty ice
because we probably have enough to do
the research
probably i saw some in uh one of these
ships i need one more i got it i got it
i got it i gotta do the research
yeah
you did it
well done you did it
guys i researched a way for us to be
less thirsty that's awesome that's a
great stuff so whatever you need most of
all right we can do a driller
a drip what is a dream
it says we can unlock lump of ice or
lump of coal
can we like break the meteors open for
it or something i [ __ ] hope so that'd
be nice let me [ __ ] tight dude guys
my grappling hook hey hey bob you see
this thing here
it's uh it's not got the best range to
it i thought it was kind of cool though
you got the hook from raft yeah man yeah
man man i wish people wanted to see more
of that series
yeah we should have really finished that
game guys we're idiots for not finishing
that game right yeah
idiots you know
object busy markiplier i don't think it
is i don't think that object is busy
with markiplier
it was busy with me
markiplier
everybody my name is markiplier
you okay you sound a little sick this is
how i always sound
he does it always sounds like that
always has
water by the water biden oh i don't find
it says water button oh [ __ ] dude oh i
can't wait to get steak obama i didn't
know
[ __ ] i was trying to get there i
couldn't [ __ ] get there god damn it
stink obama really got me guys
dude i would like to think that stake
obama is just like a well done cheap
ribeye steak with a bunch of ketchup on
it it goes great with van buren broccoli
you gotta go back to like
reagan nixon
nixon trifle the nixon trifle how about
that the vampirin broccoli is like a
time delay on me
it's becoming funny as you remember that
oh wait that is a president
sorry my presidential knowledge i should
leave the last three years also is it
better is it better or worse if it's ven
broccoli oh you want some trump turnips
everybody
no
no no no no no no i'm good i had enough
you can you can eat it with your clinton
cutlery
keep going keep going man keep going oh
man bring it home wade
oh
come on get me there
come on
you're bush beans that's already a thing
[Laughter]
[ __ ] bush's baked beans baby
oh [ __ ]
i don't know why that one made me have a
hysterical lamb for 10 seconds good god
also i made a backpack at home i did
guys what do you think a backpack would
do i'm hitting the not breaks we're
going to probably open up another row or
two of our inventory yeah uh it did not
i made it and guess what it did
what it says i can equip one more heavy
item
oh what the [ __ ] is that then i know
what is that it's like my grappling hook
is a heavy item i guess i don't know man
like another gun or something maybe no
way my dude
this grappling hook is the most useless
thing because you could just go get the
thing
it has like a two foot range this is the
most useless [ __ ] i've ever seen
what's happening i'm stuck in like i'm
stuck in build mode guys i found a bug
immediately it's fully broken
all right well good game guys
oh you're placing a box for me
i know that's what i thought was broken
oh well i see the box it makes you feel
any better why do i say anything out
loud jesus christ
i thought maybe it was just my build
menu
oh you're placing a box for
[Laughter]
me i understand
i thought i was doing something else i'm
placing a box
you solved all my problems
god damn it it says you're out of iron
maybe that's your problem
i think we need to make some copper
goddammit stop placing boxes bob you're
placing too many boxes
how what other way could i get it out of
this made me laugh till i had the pp not
gonna i can i can punch while i'm
placing a box that's something
you shoot can you shoot
i can't draw my weapon
all right no
i can go to space
i'm literally placing a box from a
thousand miles away right can anyone see
that bob we got enough boxes today yeah
yeah
cool
i was gonna hang out here back there
then that's fine i guess
[Music]
wow nice grapple man dude sick grappling
hook dude it saves me so much time
trust me
trust me why why why are you always
behind me
huh behind who i'm always wade okay
never mind i'm sorry i'm standing on our
train i'll try to avoid it right behind
me i'm in the middle of the world's
largest train and you're two inches away
from me it's basically gonna be placed
in some proximity to you no no you keep
moving away from you move out of my way
you don't stay behind me you move
you like [ __ ] move bob sounds like
you got some issues man i'm angry
i can tell
with the feet of it there's bad guys in
this next area i'm not going to be able
to shoot him just so you know what if it
reaches fixed whatever yeah it'll fix it
they'll fix it what if i what if i
construct your boxes you were making
did that fix it i no because it's this
is the box that's the troubles what if
you place that right here what if you
place it i can't i can't do anything uh
i see i see i see oh wait you know what
nope that didn't solve my problem either
i've got so much wood i've got like 20
something wood what happens if i get off
the train in here is that bad
oh apparently that is bad
i still see your box bob
yeah i know i'm me too man
all right well move as far away from you
as possible i think i think this is a
good i think it was a good stopping
place i think you've learned you're
being shot at
oh god i can't i can't gun it's all you
guys all right i got this watch i'll go
i have 20.
i'm not paying attention
i'm just going to go punch the [ __ ] out
of some of these guys don't worry
nice
man i can't hit this serpentine
serpentine
yeah
i can't punch them either my punches
don't actually do anything oh no they do
okay good that's right i have very
little health left
ow [ __ ] terminator bob out here
punching everyone to death
honestly
whoa i'm just side angling here wow
oh yeah you there's like some weird
leaning around cover mechanic yeah that
happens sometimes
i literally killed all of them
i killed like seven dudes over here nice
man very proud of you take that you
useless piece of [ __ ] all right i'm
right here man i'm not not you not you
these guys i'm insulting these guys oh
oh we need to crack open our box before
we end oh wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait i was see
that i want to see that yeah yeah yeah
it seems like your construction box is
gone i know it's right look it's right
there oh there there it is you're right
it's right there but you picked up the
sacrificial table uh
let's take a look here it's gotta be
around here somewhere
it was over by like it's up here it's up
here it's right here
up here everyone ready for this [ __ ] i'm
so ready i'm on my way
i'll wait i'll be respectful i'll wait
slap her on you ready bob
squoosh
yes
all the green stuff what is that what's
that purple thing i don't know
i don't have enough space for it it's a
mushroom
okay that
was nice
favorite treat
oh we can get a refleemo
there's a dude in a box here there's a
dude in the box what do you mean box
come over to the sacrificial table
and we're at the sacrificial table come
here look at that look a roof
box
sacrifice him wait it's in my backpack
what does that mean he squeaked why is
he squeaking i don't like that it sounds
like you're torturing is it on my back
no it's not
can you like put it in one of your slots
or something
someone else pick them up because it
went right in my backpack and i gotta
make some space oh there we go uh oh
this may have fixed me
no i can't i can't place them why can't
i play something uh oh oh no oh my god i
broke her fleebo
oh okay
hey your face oh man
oh my god
oh refleebo you saved me all right put
reflemo in the refleemo thing what do
you think happens if i shoot him what's
the reflex is it this thing yeah that
thing yeah it's the standing desk uh
we're here
oh he's horrible
oh my god he's high as [ __ ] oh yeah wow
he is actually high wait does anyone see
the red reflemo okay
randomly
it's not me is it i got my gun out oh it
is me oh
it's me i think oh thank god okay put
another one down i apparently gave you
the virus wait yeah play somewhere or
something
not very funny is it i should have i
should say if i haven't saved this whole
time everybody i think reflemo has an
important message for us okay cool
what's that
look at him
why would he say that
oh what a mean what a mean reflame bow
reflex
what's his name mark stinky
yeah
ah that's so funny right mark hang on
man hang on hang on
just wait for his name
hang on uh-huh
look at it now
it still says mark stinky for me do i
like go away and come back yeah go away
come back
boob is good farned
bob is in good farmed
what kind of insult is that it's not an
insult it's just saying your good friend
oh well that's
both inaccurate and adorable
all right anyway that's it for me you
can build up this this game to like you
have a whole train car
with like an engine and guns and like
all this stuff so there's a lot to this
game so there's a lot yet to do there's
a lot yet to do
and we wasted our one mushroom so that
now bush's beans
no it's last name bush beans
no bush
beets beans
glad you guys noticed all right well bye
later skaters later thanks for hanging
out yeah oh
i yeah i exited the game the thing
closed yeah nicely done yeah yeah
i'm gonna go i'm gonna end my stream i'm
gonna go
do stuff
all right have fun good all right bye
[Music]
you